welcome to New Zealand Chinese language
week in the Waimea career we have our
own special relationship with China
through our sister city connection with
the inshi prefecture
back in 2018 I had the privilege of
visiting Wuhan and other areas of China
you have a very beautiful country
the sister city relationship provides
opportunities to enhance our
understanding of Chinese culture much
like New Zealand Chinese language week
I encourage you to get involved in this
year's theme sharing our stories by
sharing your stories of Chinese Heritage
or culture
or by trying out some phrases like daja
Hull hello everyone
you can find out more ways to get
involved by visiting nzclw.com